hi there it's video producer Andy Bauman
standing in for reviewer Miguel
Concepcion to tell you about fourths of
Motorsports six
racing games have gotten to that point
where it's fans of lost count of the
number of times we've driven down the
straightaways vert America and even the
curves of the fictional Bernese Alps but
because it offers substantial new
features while still feeling familiar
for two motorsport six is another great
reason to get back in the driver's seat
stories of motorsport is the core motive
for to success goal driven single-player
experience neatly organized in sets of
five themes it presents the game's main
racing disciplines in inventive ways
that keep you entertained while you get
accustomed to most of the games tracks
and car classes developer turn 10
studios effectively sells the journey of
progressing through car classes and eras
with appropriate rewards both practical
and superficial that offer a great sense
of accomplishment you won credits one of
the reasons why Forza is generally
considered a much more accessible racing
simulator than safe Gran Turismo is how
it handles penalties four to six doesn't
believe in punishment instead it starts
with a low score baseline and it adds
point rewards based on how much want to
challenge yourself whether that's
turning off assists or increasing the
drive ATAR difficulty both games
effectively communicate the drawbacks of
not embracing the genuine driving
simulation experience boertie is just
much friendlier at it with the promise
of greater rewards motivating you to
become a smarter and more effective
driver
one of four to six destiny features as a
modifier system that's inspired by halo
skulls with mods that offer positive
add-ons and reward driven challenges
called dares whatever your set up mods
add flavor to the routine of gunning
first place
closing the gap between the leader is
tough enough but activating a mod that
gives you bonus credits with every
perfect turn is attempting enough
challenge to take you out of your
comfort zone such multitasking
sensations brings unexpected and
appreciated depth to four to six
ever since four to five player based
driver tires have taught us to expect
the unexpected
the dravite rai system where opponents
tendencies are defined by real-world
players
results in a wide spectrum of behavior
and skill this is key because part of
succeeding in four to six is learning
how to capitalize on your competitors
mistakes it's important to be prepared
for sloppy opponents just as much as it
is to understand the best way to
overtake seemingly perfect racers
thankfully the drive to our system makes
for an organic learning process as you
often face drivers with distinct
presence and driving styles an aspect
that also keeps races interesting as you
spend more time with the game
four to six introduces rain and night to
the motorsport series and these not only
look amazing but they feel on par with
the rest of the games outstanding
visuals the new droplet saturated
cockpit view is even impressive enough
that it may win over people who prefer
to race with an exterior camera of
course these new weather effects
introduce difficult driving conditions
when the view is this nice you don't
mind if your tires a little less grip
just happy to be there
you know you have something great when
the only negative criticisms is kept to
a modest list of forgivable nitpicks the
pre and post-race visuals as well as the
replays still run at less than 60 frames
per second while games like Forza
horizon and grid 2 weren't hindered by a
30 frames per second limit going back
and forth from the smoothness of a race
to the less than fluid scenes at the
Pitt imports of 6 is a little
off-putting then there are the low res
liveries which look great when these
designs are tearing up the track 150
miles per hour but look less stellar in
the showroom as merely the second
installment of the ports of motorsport
series for the Xbox one
Forza Motorsport 6 not only keeps up
with the high bar set by 5 it
capitalizes on that foundation of
quality especially from a Content
standpoint while the mod system and the
weather effects are reasons enough for
the force of 5 enthusiasts to seriously
consider the sequel the abundance of
difficulty in assist options make 4 to 6
and immensely accessible and enjoyable
driving simulation for newcomers